hey guys I'm Ryan right hey guys I'm
Mary Jane Watson hi today we're gonna be
talking about some news that's been
announced the new spider-man has been
announced with its new director John
watts I want to get John Watson of the
way never seen any of his work heard of
some of his work never actually seen it
but Tom Holland on the other hand is the
new spider-man Sally has issues with
this know you do we'll get to it I
personally don't have an issue with this
I I don't
this guy is 19 so he's around the right
age for an actor to keep aging and being
and sequels to it yeah kid in high
school yeah it's true and it means you
could sit on his face one day and he has
a genuinely nerdy look like Tobey
Maguire kind of has a nerdy we did what
Andrew Garfield Andrew Garfield was like
this guy's a [ __ ] amazing looking
spider-man you know that's what they
should have called it the amazing
looking spider-man this guy looks the
nerdiest out of the three but it works
them and nerdy the right word yeah he's
got a geeky look not like drop-dead
gorgeous but he has that look like he
looks very likable but he could also
play a very like you know like Charlie
from perks of being a wallflower sort of
character sure but I think that he is
like the geekiest looking one of them
all like he just gives off that
impression like I'm sure if you
submitted headshots they'd be like let's
cast him for the geek role that's how he
minded that role in the Billy Elliot
play no I'm Coolio it's a geek like yeah
he looked like Jamie Bell yeah it gets
me super psyched to see him as
spider-man is he released footage like
this guy can do like flips he could do
like awesome [ __ ] flips and he's got
like some parkour skills he could that's
what makes it awesome is because I would
always get distracted by is that really
Andrew Garfield under the suit is that
really Tobey Maguire under the seat I
think it would be cool if they actually
had some sequences where he's not
wearing the mask he's actually doing all
this yeah he's actually doing all the
crazy acrobatic stuff because that's
what was really appealing to me I'm like
whoa this guy got great feedback for the
impossible seeing him die like he has
these special talents that I didn't know
about it seemed you that was one the
those things because I love seeing an
actor who has more than just acting to
offer and they can really take it and
throw it into an action role because
this guy clearly is hired more than just
his acrobatic skills his acting ability
he is shown is really good it's not like
look at Taylor Lautner for example oh my
god
Kol honor was a shitty actor right but
then they found out he could do martial
arts and [ __ ] so they put him in some
martial arts films but he still sucked
but you know put him on the level if you
sure he's got Fame but not respect be
honest ok that was your spiel let me
just um give my spiel of how it's like
to not be a movie fanatic and just a
regular normal person reacting to this
news
basically honestly at first when I saw
he was hired I was really mad because I
know who he was that's basically why I
got mad because I was like who is this
kid and then I saw he's from the UK I
was like he's not even American
like what here's the thing though I'm
still little I'm sure a lot of people
are still really mad that Andrew
Garfield isn't gonna be spider-man
anymore and I'm all over them I'm a
little salty about it because like how
many times they read on spider-man and
now they're doing this like immediately
after like there's no break like
Marvel's just like jumping right into it
I don't know I have a problem with that
but that being said once I did the
research on this kid I realized like
he's got a lot more going for him than
just acting I mean he is like really
incredible he's got way more Skills than
you know I would say feel like Dylan
O'Brien don't know Brian's a type that
he's just really hot and he has a lot of
girl fans I just think he's really hot
and he can like pull off doing action
because he's just hot but this kid seems
to have something different he seems to
have the sort of acting style that I
feel like is oscar-worthy yeah
especially based off the feedback that
he got from the impossible um but he's
unknown which kind of makes it fun for
us cuz we don't really know it'll be
easier to buy a role when you don't
really know the actors yeah cuz you can
just see them as that character yeah and
Marvel does a great job with casting I
personally am not bothered by at first I
was bothered by it but now it's like it
doesn't bother me how fast Marvel is
moving on this because Marvel
they've been tracked they've been saying
when it was just with Sony that they
have
figure out a way to get spider-man in
the Avengers so they've been wanting to
get him in this Avengers world for a
long time pressures of what I'm having a
problem with it's that after that
they're planning to do a reboot film
yeah that's what I have a problem with
what's wrong with that it's so sudden I
don't know I feel like people are just
sick of him not like sick of people
messing with spider-man I know what if
one person's gonna go around spider-man
it's gonna be more injured Garfield's
fanbase though was like ridiculous I
mean it's ridiculous how big a fan base
he has so they're all really mad of
course well this is fan base
I trust Marvel I trust them with their
casting so when I found out about it I
was kind of mad but then I was like you
know what they know what they're doing
but I just hope that these fans can get
over it because it doesn't seem like
they're gonna get over it anytime soon
that's all I'm saying
um something about Andrew Garfield
though like seeing how he was responding
to things and how he was talking about
it in interviews even when he was still
spider-man it seemed like he didn't give
a [ __ ] anymore he still cared about
spider-man he was just mad that Sony was
messing around with it like they did but
they said they weren't gonna do they
like topped it up like they were gonna
do better than Raimi did and then they
ended up making the same mistakes Andrew
Garfield put so much trust into Sony and
this in his character in the films and
then they [ __ ] up so that I could see
I would be pretty mad if I if I was the
leading role and put my all into the
character that I loved so much and hope
that it would be better than what
previous films showed and then they went
and just made the same mistakes I'd be
pretty mad at you then again I wouldn't
have trash-talked them if I wanted to
keep my roles so well here's my rebuttal
um get over it good you don't have to
tell me I mean
I mean you all have to get over what's
happened has happened and this is what's
happening now so what matters is is this
going to be cool and it's marble so I I
trust marble like they're one of the few
studios around like yeah whatever they
do I'm pretty much there even if the
trailer doesn't look that appealing I'm
oh I tend to be surprised and be like
it's a pretty good movie I trust what
they're doing Tom Hall and has a lot of
qualities that make them a unique
standout as opposed to other actors when
I was hearing like Dylan O'Brien and
who's that guy's dick you want to suck
logan lerman logan lerman and I'm like
these are guys are like good-looking
people who could play nerds but you know
like this guy I like his look it seems
like yeah he's perfectly cast you know
he's [ __ ] intelligent dude we were
watching interviewing these guys very
likey I was younger than me but I'm like
[ __ ] this guy feels like he's 10 years
older than me yeah so Marvel smart and
basically all in all guys just give Tom
Holland a chance I guess the biggest
disappointment out of all this is the
way they announced it yeah it was so
casual that I kind of don't fully
believe it they were like hey here's a
nice better man there's the nice yeah
I'm like I mean the thing we've all been
talking about forever now you're saying
like yeah now that I think about it they
probably did that because they probably
knew people were gonna get really mad
about it oh yeah with risk-taking
casting people always get pissed yeah so
I feel like if they were to have casted
don't know Brian they probably would
have done a huge thing about it but with
this they're keeping it on the down-low
because people are like who is this guy
yeah and plus the director - a lot of
people don't know that is yeah so you're
taking on but that's what's cool about
Marvel is they're able that they're
willing to take chances like that and
don't sell out so yeah I mean sometimes
they sacrifice certain storytelling to
tie it in with their Avengers role more
but overall like Marvel knows what
they're doing and I think it's cool when
they hire like someone who's like Jon
Favreau for Iron Man he did elf before
he and the closest thing Iron Man was
like is the thorah so he did Iron Man
and it's like that's what I mean that
type
casting kenneth branagh for thort like
their choices for directing tends to be
surprising so I'm not worried about the
direction of this I feel like they're
going to know what they're doing and
it's gonna be cool just to see them yeah
they finally are figuring this out to
get Spidey in the world I mean say
exciting I'm excited I mixed I'm
exciting I'm exciting I'm fun I am love
me anyway guys thanks for tuning in to
the channel if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
you can check out salamander Sally's
channel Mary Jane Watson
Mary Jane Watson channel she still wants
to be Mary Jane and one day it'll happen
one day it'll happen when Mary Jane
starts working at a strip club and you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter and vine where if we get enough
followers we can get more product
placement that's right already got
plenty and we want more because money is
good